[Applause]
here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back on the
internet and look we got for two
scientists on this it's a good thing
IQ doesn't weigh now I'm no dummy
exactly I am actually a dummy on this on
the areas where you're an expert but
let's ask dr. Lyman somebody asked as an
expert on nuclear proliferation
proliferation how likely is it that a
nuclear weapon will be used in the next
30 years
oh well that's not really a scientific
question that's more a political
question the aftermath is a scientific
question
I got a scientific question for you I've
heard that if India and Pakistan who
both have nuclear weapons and who might
use them because they're just [ __ ]
nuts enough to try if the cricket match
goes badly but they each have about a
hundred nuclear I've heard that if they
set up a hundred nuclear weapons goodbye
earth well certainly that always a happy
question a nuclear exchange in the South
Asia would certainly be a bad day
there's no hundred nuclear bombs went
off I've heard that it would create a
kind of nuclear winter screw up the
atmosphere and that we'd all die within
a year or so well I think there are some
uncertainties about that but I wouldn't
want I wouldn't want to do the
experiment it makes the fish look good
those those climate models that we use
today by models I mean mathematical
things really go back to Carl Sagan a
nuclear winter and Carl Sagan he was our
professor right now right so people
would you take his course I did yeah he
didn't show up much to your point that's
right
that's exactly
didn't really show up well he did when I
was there seriously man we were there at
the same time a year ahead of you
because the big turning point for him
was with the launch of Voyager I think
the big turning point for him was doing
the Tonight Show yeah well he did that a
lot he would come in and we would sing
the song but he in 1977 that's when the
Voyager was launched and it just left
the solar system officially a missile
win students I'm this toy is there such
a thing as coincidence doctors yeah of
course it was a trick question
no it's faith of course is such a thing
as coincidence okay will Voyager one
entering interstellar space interstellar
space what do you think need to be the
next steps in human space exploration
hmm so no you know I have a day job I'm
the head of the Planetary Society which
was started by Carl say I'm CEO no so
Chuck there's that pay a little bit when
we turn the corner we're growing for the
first time in 14 years so anyway
scientists more and singers less no but
here's the thing there are two questions
besides saying well it's working hard or
hardly working
there are two questions that trouble us
all where did we come from
and are we alone and if you meet
somebody who says I've never asked those
two questions they're lying
everybody is wondered that where did I
come from am I alone if you want to
answer those questions no I think it
even more basic question is why is there
anything that's so cool it always gets
back to that it can so get this but it
is an astonishing thing until you know
it's an astonishing thing that we are
made of exploded stars we are made of
Stardust and if we are Stardust stars
I've got two most star stuff with Carl
Sagan but Stardust is kind of a nut
happy song right so it is really if that
doesn't fill you with reverence that we
are at least one of the ways that the
universe knows itself that is quite an
insight and that is a result of science
especially astronomy and so the missions
to these planets especially Mars may
very well in the next decade dare I say
it but dodge the world why do why do
fire alarm batteries always diet 4 a.m.
making my energy engineers have done our
best and we tell you please replace the
batteries regularly thorium that's where
do you get thorium not so easy we all
are a.m. right oh I've tried to get it a
comer easier I got that cheap it's it's
so cut with baby laxative but thorium I
get odds like you get your high for like
half hours totally sucks Michael Steele
do you think the Republican presidential
candidate in 2016 will support same-sex
marriage good political question is cool
it's a very good political question and
I think likely I'll say this if he does
probably well it depends in the primary
one in the front that's wrong cannot do
it in the price I was going won't in the
primary
if doesn't the primary just you know
just he would have to have an evolution
between the primaries anyway I think I
think that that is shamak many Democrats
have had that same and they had that
same it was hysterical in 24 hours they
had that evolution you know how they
always do it with they use their kids as
cover I know is that my kids have gay
friends he came over for Thanksgiving
dinner and none of them tried to leap
across the table and [ __ ]
a bill is a it's a process it's a
flashback to we're having a black friend
was popular your rights like you know I
have a black friend so therefore you
know but you know I've had no friend
when it wasn't popular okay no I I think
I think that that issue is going to be
one that will actually be a sleeper in
the in Republican primary because it's
going to be an undercurrent because
there are there are a lot of young
Republicans especially who have been
pushing yeah no seriously a lot of Young
Republicans a lot of a lot of young
millennial Republicans have been pushing
the party on this issue so I think those
voices are going to be there alright
Matt how do you get prosecutors
interested in Wall Street well I gotta
say you know Wall Street got their man
Spitzer right the one guy who knew how
to keep an eye on Wall Street you know
got lumped in with weiners dick and
right now he's right yeah that's why he
lost yeah I was really sad that Xfinity
that he didn't win but you're absolutely
right I mean you know he took on Wall
Street and it's impossible to win an
election in New York if you take on the
financial services industry and I mean
it would be like taking on all the
studios here in LA and trying to win an
election here it's it's just not doable
alright and it's just sad that he didn't
win so they the Wall Street backed his
opponent guy who doesn't [ __ ] broster
everybody back I mean yeah exactly
exactly so what do you get for that I
mean well I guess that's been an old
question what do you mean what are you
what do you get for 4,000 bucks an hour
I've often wondered you know
the reason part name is downtown
the reason parts are so expensive for
airplanes is they're certified you know
everything this one's good this one's
the right mixture of aluminum it's been
heat-treated the right away it's been
cocoa those machine rivals we call them
nuclear grade great nuclear grade the
two scientists talk about horse for a
minute
[Music]
Real Time with Bill Maher and Friday
night at 10:00 passed bill and his
guests to her questions right after the
show
at hbo.com